[Music]
once you start climbing then the biggest
hazard is avoiding all those big icicles
they are huge like the size of a family
car
those daggers are
really not attached that well to the
rock and sometimes it takes just a small
kick and they
just collapse and fall down
[Music]
my name is clement premerl
i'm an ice climber and adventurer
my climbing has taken me to so many
different places all over the world
then hong kong falls came into the radar
and it just changed everything i mean
it's the steepest ice you can find
anywhere
once you're there and you're walking
towards the ice fall
you just get this feeling how big it is
i mean it's huge and it's steep
to have overhanging eyes it's really
rare
usually ice climbs are formed vertically
we didn't see overhanging eyes before
hamcon falls
i do believe
life starts when you step out of the
comfort zone climbing forces you to go
outside of your comfort zone it forces
you
to look out for this fragile line
between
having good time and not risking too
much
fear is present a lot
but
once i'm there and once i start to work
on the route
the fair just goes away there's no more
fear it's just about climbing and having
good times
[Music]
you